hey everyone and welcome to console crew
your weekly roundup of all the biggest
news from playstation
xbox and nintendo did you just dab
it's been a while this year has been a
while since anyone has dabbed
uh this week it has been packed we've
got xboxes
uh cloud gaming stuff we have the
playstation state of play as well as new
releases and upcoming direct
over on the nintendo side so to dig into
it all i am joined by xbox expert jordan
remay
yo and playstation pro the dab
connoisseur
tomorrow hussein
oh i'm too old to dab i think i just
threw my back out
i was gonna say that the dab king but he
has just thrown his back out doing it
yeah i've just
don't like i was just checking and 2021
advice update
still don't dab it's bad it looks bad
and it will hurt
it will hurt you probably so just leave
the dab into the kids
talk all right for weekly episodes of
console crew make sure to like this
video and subscribe to gamespot we
are weekly on fridays let's jump into
the playstation news
okay for context we're filming this
separately we're filming it right after
playstation state of play
however there's been a lot of
playstation news this week so tim
please go through it for us all right
speed round so first things first
i'm the realist um no way psvr
2 has been announced not much details
about it we know it's got one cable
i think sony realized that its previous
setup was a bit messy and
uh gamers do not like too many wires so
they're trying to fix that up
play at home is back so you will be
getting some free games and some free
anime they're partnering with a bunch of
other third-party companies to try and
make
your stay at home uh time a little more
interesting and there's gonna be some
more pc
releases for playstation games starting
with hot commodity
days gone you asked for it
you got it but you know it's nice to see
playstation having an ongoing commitment
to putting stuff on pc
it's nice to see playstation going they
said they want bloodborne on pc
put days gone on pc you're gonna have to
let that go
um he will never let go okay as well as
horizon coming in 2021
gran turismo 7 is now moving to 2022
so if you like your ultra simulated
racing games
uh on the gran turismo variety you're
gonna have to wait a little longer
but the big deal was stay oh play it was
a nice mix
i'll say that i was i was genuinely
after like the jim ryan news and
interview in gq this week i was fully
expecting to see
a horizon update they didn't mention god
of war
uh in that interview that he did earlier
this week and so i was like oh maybe
they'll do something no
but we did get um a bunch of cool
looking indie games we got to see more
of uh
kana kina kina bridger
bridge of spirits i just love your
spirits um
as well as you know a better look at
death loop
and all the final fantasy 7 remake news
so for me it was like a really nice mix
of games and i think you know obviously
annapurna is in there got another look
at like knockout city and crash dlc
it was a good mix um for me it was that
meme of you know the shaquille o'neal
asleep
until until death live came in and then
it's just i wake
seafood didn't do it for you like it was
so cool seafood looked incredible i feel
like had me stirring in my sleep a bit
uh but yeah the final fantasy stuff is
really what uh got my jimmies wrestled
wow
also um before i forget um solar ash i
keep forgetting the name of that game
but it looks really really cool
yeah the final fantasy stuff so that
leaked on
4chan um on wednesday
and so no one thought it was
no really thought it was real because
they uh they said that they would be
charging 60 dollars
for the new version but it looks like if
you have it on ps4 you get the free
upgrade
but it does i mean first of all whoever
is editing trailers
over at square enix what was it quality
of life
graphics on playstation 5. maybe
how but it also does look like the ufe
is only going to be on the ps5 version
because they were like oh free upgrade
from ps4 to ps5
and then you can buy your themes to be
very unclear
yeah at the time of recording that's not
100 it just
everything seems to be worded in a way
that encourages people to upgrade to the
playstation via version
and that's where it's graphics available
fog new lighting it made the sewer
levels more foggy which makes me
want to play it again even less i'm like
making it harder to see
banging music down there though hey
that's coming on spotify yeah
soundtrack is gonna be on spotify so
love to see that
and then there's other final fantasy
mobile games including
a battle royale a final fantasy battle
royale
i honestly of all the things on my
gaming in 2021 bingo card i did not
expect a final fantasy 7 battle royale
i'm gonna try it i'm gonna try it i'm
gonna go yeah i mean that's the thing it
did look
pretty good they've also announced a a d
make of the final
fantasy 7 remake which is based on the
original final fantasy vii
which is not confusing at all if you fee
i mean
tam you reviewed it for us you give it a
10 out of 10.
are you mad about yuffie potentially
being locked behind a next-gen version
not really uh i think i think it does
kind of
i wish i'm hoping that they do have
other options um
available um i i honestly don't know
i can't speak to the development um like
when did it start did it
did the yuffie stuff start development
when they were working on playstation 5
stuff when they moved on to the next
chapter of it and that's what
as a result is is kind of like means
that it has to be played on that console
it does feel slightly anti-consumer i
wish that
the that they i hope that they make it
available on ps4 considering that's
where the large majority of their fan
base is
um and and you know i i hope that that's
that's available to some degree because
you know um
that is the best way to make it you know
and
give the fans what they deserve um it
looks like it's gonna be
integrated i'm gonna say wait i'm going
i'm going for like the breaking news
from the ping from chris pereira in the
news chat is that um
time you want to say final fantasy 7
remake integrate on ps5 is gonna cost
69.99 if you're buying it fresh i think
i guess it's kind of like a whole new um
version of the game
and then a digital deluxe version is
89.99
and both of those versions will include
yuffie
um content 69.99 so
sony's really going in on playstation 5
being
seven seventy dollars huh
all right technically it's a nice price
but it's not actually a nice price is it
well it does also come out on the um
the 9th of june well actually hang on i
thought it was 10th of june but um it
says i believe
it says 9th of june on the playstation
store which is maybe
6 9 which is nice unlocks and possibly
yeah the only thing different in the
digital deluxe version
is um you get a digital artbook and a
mini soundtrack
and cackstar item but you also get the
cacti and then the standard edition
yeah uh i yeah i don't know it's kind of
weird
it's kind of it seems like they're
forcing you into an upgrade which i'm
not super into
but personally i love like that game
enough to
buy again i mean at least at least
saves work and if you do have it on ps4
then you do get the free upgrade and so
that in a way is very pro consumer
however if
it's the yuffie stuff that is going to
be the real test of and that is
also going to be i think this is going
to be a very interesting conversation
going on
as it's not just as simple as the xbox
ecosystem where
it works on everything um you know
playstation hashtag believes in
generations
so i think they're gonna want you to
move over one way or another
the ones the one thing i would probably
recommend is there's like what four
months until that's out
like there's decent chances of final
fantasy vii remake ps4 going on sale
um or even being purchased like uh
secondhand
slash digitally on sale so if you spot
it and you think i want to play the
yuffie stuff on ps5 or i want to play
the game on ps5
it might be a good opportunity to just
grab it if it's on sale and then do the
free upgrade path
um if you do buy the disk based version
obviously make sure you've got a ps5
with a disk in it
this lot on it otherwise you'll be out
of luck the biggest thing for me to come
out of the
playstation state of play because like i
said it was like a nice one it wasn't
you know like last summer's one where it
was like huge reveal huge reveal huge
reveal this was just like a kind of nice
all-rounder
um is it i discovered that integrate is
a real word
and not just something that's square and
exciting that was your big take away
from that was my biggest takeaway
square units are known to make up words
man they you can't trust them with words
what's been going on um in the valley of
the jolly green giant i love that
it's just going to be a recurring theme
probably well phil
spencer basically said that he wants
more
developers to just be creating games
natively for the cloud and that
developers are going to be creating
these games
specifically for a cloud-based gaming
service hosting hundreds of thousands of
players and
it basically just sounds like stadia it
just sounds like xbox is basically being
like well stadia is
just not gonna do it then then we will
we'll take this market
and they probably have the
infrastructure to actually do it well
it's wild because thinking about all the
when the original vision for crackdown 3
was announced they were like yeah they
were going to have this mode and it's
all going to be done in the cloud and
you get
all this extra processing power and then
crown 3 came out and wasn't very good
but i recently actually did a feature
about the kind of rise and fall of
stadia and all the comments in that
video were like
when did it rise and i'm like please
the thing is is that i think that's a
very negative way of looking at it
because the promise of stadia was
incredible and if you go back and watch
that original pitch for stadia
they talk about the promise that
developers will just be able to make
anything in the cloud and they'll have
all this power and so if xbox is
actually going to be the people to do it
and unlike google will probably actually
support it
for more than 18 months stadia's like
biggest problem is that there just
wasn't enough to play on it and there
wasn't like enough coming to it
xbox doesn't really have that yeah
and like to be like i'm not a big
stadium defender but
cyberpunk ran best on stadia like um
destiny 2 was great on stadium so there
are definitely risers but yeah
when stadia came out we were all like
holy crap this could be amazing
and the promise of you know developing
in the cloud
is amazing but then we all looked at
what is that google graveyard
website and we're like yeah we'll see
we'll see and
i'm not surprised at all that this is
the way it went um it's a shame but
like lucy you said if microsoft is
looking at them and going we can do that
we can do that better that's amazing
because one
big phil knows what he's doing and isn't
gonna like abandon
uh projects before they've been given a
real chance to see if they can hit a
sprint
um and really pick up the pace and build
some momentum
and developers should benefit from it
although to be fair this whole like
summit that he was talking about talking
about stadia at i
i really don't care all that much about
it what i care about and what i think
the fans care about is the fact that we
got
another look at the background of
phil spencer's office space and as we
know like he hid the series s in the
background
at one point and there was a trailer
where we got to see the
really cool xbox headset like in the
trailer so it's like
details there must be hints there must
be some
hint at a new game or piece of tech or
service in the background of this shot
this is this is a new
this is a new area for him like i've not
as has he been seen in this
space before so i think this is his act
i think he's on the xbox campus i think
this is his actual office because
it's his wife's office that he normally
does yeah that's where his cat is
usually running around
yeah and no cat hair no dining table
looking set up so this is probably his
actual office you can tell from the nine
xbox controllers in the background
so this is our blade runner moment
because obviously like everyone's just
kind of picking through the background
and obviously the big hubbub has been
he has the luden's statue and so
everyone's like oh my god are they
buying kojima productions
and you know what probably not no but
you definitely
zoom in the background i mean
there's a nintendo switch right there
what's on that
can we zoom in a little bit closer can
we zoom in
is that bayonetta 3 it is confirmed
phil spencer is buying bayonetta 3. like
she used to be on xbox
yeah she was she was on xbox i like
we're going to spark
some stuff i know big article where
someone's just going to take us
fully on faith and be like oh god i hope
so
i really do hope so after
last week's nintendo direct i thought it
was going to be a quite
a quiet week for nintendo but no they're
coming out all guns blazing so we got
bravely default 2
releasing today uh we've got persona 5
strikers that came out earlier this week
which i'm very very excited to jump into
because i have missed
my team we've also got tony hawk pro
skater 1-2 the remaster
coming to switch later this year thanks
to a
very cute but obviously uh
pre-planned little tweet exchange
between tony hawk and crash bandicoot
but i thought that was very cute
nonetheless
what a world we live in where tony hawk
is having a conversation with crash
bandicoot
i know but you know honestly i'm
that that that remake was really really
good so yeah very happy it's coming
i'm super excited and unlike tony hawk
uh who somehow is able to do what was it
420s still at his age 20s isn't it
900 900 i don't know anything about
skateboarding and still live
um i did a dab earlier and my back still
hurts but i am still excited
about um playing these games i feel like
portable is the way to go for this
specific tony hawk game because it's got
so much to offer
so yeah i am super super happy that
crash bandicoot could make it happen for
us
thanks scratch um we just got republic
commando which jordan i know you're
uh excited for go let's go let's go that
game's so
good i wish they had updated the
graphics and who would have thought that
blinks the time sweeper made it happen
for us to get us republican
last week we were talking about you know
like oh nintendo didn't really announce
anything for zelda's actual birthday and
i feel so bad so
ian lack in the comment section last
week was was like fingers triple crossed
for a sequel announcement on zelda's
anniversary
nothing you thought nope no sorry
sorry man but you know they did announce
a new smash direct i don't know why i
said smash so weirdly i should have put
the emphasis on direct instead of phone
smash
but to talk about pirate and mithra
coming to smash so that's for next week
we'll obviously be talking about our
next week's show um but that means
we've got two more smash characters in
this
pass tony hawk and crash bandicoot well
i mean
oh i think it's pretty obvious that i
think tony like when i saw when i saw
the tony hawk announcement for switch i
was like
tony hawk and smash like that would be
incredible like would it be
a life-like rendition of him or would it
be like a cartoon
i think it would be the most it would be
that much station just
put him in the original tony hawk
playstation one
like model where he looks just like a
bunch of cubes
smashing up to the other and just plays
goldfinger every time yeah on his stage
and then his stage's warehouse the best
thing could be like you could have him
jump and if you time
your like a button press on a platform
landing he could
like the animation would look like he
bailed on a trick
but he's got active hit frames so if you
do it into enemies it'll knock them away
that would be sick let me design tony
hawk for smash
so we yeah we've got like they also
uh nintendo did tweet they were like
yeah you can have this direct next week
but there will be no
other announcements so don't get excited
but i think
trying to guess what the announcements
are is part of the fun so
for next week i i would love it in the
comments below if you have people that
you want to see
in smash tony hawk has already taken
crash bandicoot a possibility
jordan tam who do you think could go in
smash because bearing in mind we've had
steve from minecraft
anything is possible i would like
hat kid from a hat in time and
when this next announcement happens i
want hornet
from silk song and for that reveal to
immediately proceed the reveal trailer
of
hollow knight silk songs release date
which will be my birthday
and the world will be perfect and i'll
have cake
for breakfast and ice cream for lunch
and cake again for dinner i i think it's
going to be a pokemon thing
because it's the pokemon oh it's the
anniversary it's going to be a gym
leader
instead of pokemon trainer so it'll be
like come on already
yeah but like it will be a gym leader so
you play as a gym leader so i'll be like
oh
sabrina is here and she's got all of her
ghost puck i want sabrina
and gengar that's what i want i want
sabrina haunter gengar give me that
i'm happy put the ash in smash yeah put
the ash in smash
or it might be like team rocket has
joined the fight
and it's like you guys that would be
that would actually be pretty good that
would be so cool
that would be pretty good you get like
you can pilot
you can swap like the between jesse and
james
and then based on that uk i don't know
who their current ones are but like
ekans and
coughing and meowth and that would be
pretty cool
just happen that they never explode off
the stage they always do
they're going flying off into the yeah
and it always plays a cutscene every
time
so you have to watch them scream team
rocket is blasting off again
oh my god in the middle of a combo right
now
thank you once again for joining us on
this episode of console crew we'll be
back again
next friday and man what a week it's
been i'm gonna go remember
do not dab dab don't just done i
confirmed it
dabbing is over
[Music]
you